i'm alan and welcome to my channel where
today uh i thought that i would do an
ending explained video for 12 minutes
which you are seeing gameplay of right
now um this game came out a couple of
weeks ago now
and has certainly had its fair share of
controversy
um
virtually everything i feel like has
been unpacked it's definitely been
talked about a lot um but i've seen a
lot of mixed responses to what the
ending of this game actually means and i
just kind of wanted to share what my
interpretation was i haven't looked this
up to see if you know the the general
consensus is exactly the same as what i
took uh but i did want to
mention
so stoked she paid the electricity bill
today um part of what prompted me to
make this is some people expressing
confusion about the time loop or saying
this time loop doesn't make sense
because how does this flower die if
you've not played it as you go through
these loops this flower will die or grow
these paintings also change
um and there's a very simple explanation
for that and the basics is that it's not
a real time loop
um but before we get into that you know
basically the synopsis for anyone who
might be watching this because they
don't want to play it at all and just
want to know what it's about
you get home from work you walk into
this exact room and your wife is here um
she tells you to set the dessert on the
table
uh and then you in theory you could
choose you don't actually have to do any
of this um but you essentially have 12
minutes
and at a certain point
a cop will show up at the front door he
will handcuff you and most often kill
you
um
and you have to figure out why that's
happening to try to break the loop or at
least that is uh what the
initial suggestion
seems to be
as you get through the loops you get
more information
meaning you can ask more questions on
the next loop um and you know every time
it resets and you start back at the door
and you have to start all over again so
as the story progresses it goes through
some stuff where you
uh knock your wife out by drugging her
um i think you have to do that at least
twice um you have to torture the cop who
shows up to get information from him
because he won't cooperate unless you
steal his gun and shoot him in the leg
um to get more and more information to
come to completion and at first he shows
up and is claiming to want to uh
get a pocket watch from your wife which
you in theory have never heard of before
um and he's framing her or sorry it's
suggesting that she killed her father
as the loops go on and you try to figure
out oh my god is my wife a murderer she
kept this for me this entire time she
can give you a little bit of information
when you start to suspect something or
when you prove to her that the day is
repeating
um and then eventually it comes out that
actually
uh she didn't kill him he died several
days later i was killed several days
after she had already left wherever
their home is and that her
step-brother actually was the one who
killed him
and it's someone that she was estranged
from all she knows is that he was called
monster a lot
more lips go on
through conversations with the wife and
with the cop you will eventually figure
out that the
sun here is actually
the stepbrother
uh thus meaning this is an incestuous
relationship
uh and he is the one that murdered the
father um and then you think that's all
the twists
but it's not um the actual
time loop of this game and this is what
i think the ending actually really means
um is not real so nothing that happens
in this room is actually happening these
paintings aren't actually changing based
on how far through the game you are um i
think these are both pretty late in the
game they are they're right at the end
for the loop that i'm on right now
um
because nothing in this room is is real
you never actually got to this point if
i go in here
i've got to do it before the cop gets
here i suppose i don't know how much
time i have left
accidentally clicked away there are
occasionally issues with the controls
and then we will duck down here
use the house keys on the vent
oh she's gonna get super mad huh why
would you do that you're gonna don't
worry about it don't worry about it
you're in the apartment because oh
because
i don't even and then this is going to
take me
elsewhere
hopefully it doesn't restart the loop
because i didn't shut the door
it might be an [ __ ] sometimes if i
can get it to
teleport me before she leaves i think we
might be okay
so
yeah oh he's coming back in okay
so essentially um
the room that i'm headed to right now
which is something that you'll figure
out later in the game obviously is the
only part of the game
that is actually real
um this clock on the wall is of course
real and you will head to the study
right now and that is the only part of
the game that is actually happening it
is the present um everything that's
happening in the loop is completely
fabricated in your mind uh yes the
protagonist has fallen in love with his
stepsister accidentally uh not knowing
and yes the cop seems to be the same as
the father they seem to be the same guy
because uh as the protagonist the main
character is going through
this process of talking to him he's
accepting that he has to forget that he
ever met the stepsister so he is
accepting i suspect through some kind of
hypnosis that he cannot be with her and
he has to accept that he is going to
forget her and that the stepfather is
going to help
him to forget so basically what's
happened is that in his mind as he's
going through this traumatic experience
of
forgetting the woman he's in love with
and pretending that he never knew about
any of this um which you know results in
nobody dying thankfully none of the
stuff in the room ever happening he's
going through on a loop the worst
possible outcomes or even the only
possible outcomes
to prove to himself how terrible they
are all are essentially um to to prove
to his psyche that it is not possible
for this to work out in any positive way
that it is always going to go badly
that it's a terrible idea to do this to
someone um that relates to the book that
you see her reading she's not actually
reading that book it's just a book in
the room that that he
has heard of uh the game is 12 minutes
and the the loops are 12 minutes and the
pocket watch is based on this clock
because it is a clock that is in the
real world room that he is actually in
um so no he never murders the father he
never marries
his sister
she's never pregnant none of that ever
actually happens um essentially it would
be that
there is
you know he is a bastard son you can't
and uh i'm just gonna see if i can
prolong this a little bit longer
um
he is the son he has met the the
daughter and does fall in love with her
but
that's where it ends is that he realizes
that he needs to
forget she ever existed
stepfather figures it out they have this
conversation
the actual true
finished ending
is
yeah all right him accepting
he's not going to be with us yeah i
guess
i don't remember this loop i think we'll
just i guess there is a word make it
loop again where i leave
and where she doesn't get to know why
there is
but um
yeah that's pretty much my thesis
nothing in the game is real the time
loop is not real that's why it's
imperfect why it doesn't follow
necessary time conventions like a plant
being the same and a painting changing
that's why the confusion of the cop and
the father looking like the same guy
um is not actually there it's just his
mind filling in the blanks as he's kind
of in his hypnosis state to forget that
she existed that's why the wall clock
looks the same that's why the red book
is the same
etc so none of it actually ever happened
and uh
yeah it's just you solving a puzzle
inside of your own brain really um
that's certainly what my takeaway is
at least i haven't uh read up on
other people's ending theories or
anything like that so if you have any
other takes i would love to hear them
and i'm sure that a lot of people reach
the same conclusion as me it's not like
i think i'm a genius or anything for
deciding this though i do find this game
fun to talk about um
criticisms and all i do think it's a
very interesting game to talk about and
people get very impatient when talking
about it which is something that i
always find fun in the games community
um
but yeah i just wanted to share just
because i did see a little bit of
confusion about certain facets of the
time travel which again is not actually
happening so just in case somebody
happened to be looking this up
um which i figured they would then i
thought that i would make this video to
quickly talk about it and yeah we'd love
to hear if anyone else has any other
theories or if you think my theory is
completely wrong for some reason i am
totally down to hear it um but that is
it for me today everyone hope you
enjoyed this quick video
i didn't prepare this at all so
hopefully it's not too rambly uh but
there there you go
alrighty i'll see you guys next time bye